Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here.
X-Men Apocalypse's day of reckoning has finally
arrived and I've been able to hunt down all
the (best) easter eggs and references from
the latest X-Men movie.
Of course, there will be spoilers ahead, so
if you want to avoid any spoilers, click here
for my spoiler-free review or come back after
you've seen the movie.
And as promised, I'm giving away the first
of two packs of official X-Men Apocalypse
merch on this video.
To enter the giveway you just need to subscribe
and leave a comment or reply to a comment
about your favourite easter egg in the movie.
One of the movie's best moments is when Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine emerges from his Weapon
X cell in full-on berserker mode.
The headgear and cables, belt and gadgets
around his waist, and the spikes in his torso
are a reference to his original training gear
from the Weapon X comics, written and illustrated
by Barry Windsor-Smith.
And the red light we see on his helmet is
nod to the red visor on his virtual reality
helmet in the comics.
The location where this all takes place is
Alkali Lake, which we saw in the first X-Men
trilogy and in X-Men Origins: Wolverine, although
with the changed timeline since Days of Future
Past, the Wolverine Weapon X we see here is
a new version.
And the moment where Jean Grey touches Wolverine's
head, soothes him, and restores a part of
his memory is a nod to the relationship between
Wolverine and Famke Janssen's Jean Grey in
the original X-Men trilogy, even if here it
feels rather age-inappropriate.
It's also an interesting twist on The Last
Stand where it was Logan who tried to soothe
Jean Grey from her dark Phoenix self.
And there are lots of hints that the Dark
Phoenix saga will be revisited in the X-Men
movie universe, hopefully in a more satisfying
way than it was previously.
When Jean wakes up from her nightmare, the
talk between her and Charles about a dark
power inside her together with visions of
flames is an indication of what's to come,
and her words that "I'm afraid someday I'm
going to hurt someone" are also a nod to how
she killed Scott Summers in The Last Stand.
In the final showdown Jean learns to harness
the powerful Phoenix energy when Charles pleads
with her to unleash it so they can defeat
Apocalypse.
And the moment is completed with the image
of a burning bird around Jean, with Apocalypse
proclaiming "All is revealed!"
Thanks to the popularity of Quicksilver's
amazing frozen time sequence in Days of Future
Past, Evan Peters gets not just one, but two
fantastic slow-mo scenes in X-Men: Apocalypse.
And the pizza dog that Quicksilver rescues
is an easter egg from the comics where Hawkeye
recues a dog called Lucky aka Pizza Dog.
And when Quicksilver surfs out of the exploding
X-Mansion on a table, it's a cool visual nod
to the Silver Surfer from the comics and of
course the Fantastic Four 2007 sequel Rise
of the Silver Surfer.
There's also a wink to the X-Men-themed V
Energy Drink ad that Evan Peters did when
Quicksilver stops to take a sip of the TAB
soda can from a girl holding the drink during
the X-Mansion explosion.
By the way, after the hints from Days of Future
Past, we also get an amusing confirmation
that Magneto is Quicksilver's father, as per
the comics.
The Six Million Dollar Man T-shirt that Quicksilver
wears is a wink to Apocalypse director Bryan
Singer's rumoured plans to make a big-screen
version of the 70s TV show The Six Million
Dollar Man.
And Quicksilver's room has some cool pop culture
references from the 80s such as a Ms Pac-Man
arcade game and the Knight Rider theme was
playing on his TV during the scene in his
room.
Blob from X-Men Origins: Wolverine makes a
brief appearance as the opponent Angel knocks
out before Nightcrawler is brought in to the
mutant cage fight.
This scene is also a callback to our first
introduction to Wolverine in the very first
X-Men movie when he's cage-fighting in a bar.
By the way, in X-Men Origins: Wolverine, it
was heavily implied Blob was killed, but in
this movie's new timeline, Blob, although
unconscious, seems to be alive.
There's a reference to Nightcrawler's comic
book and X-Men 2 origins in the circus when
he's introduced at the cage fight.
The fact that it's Raven aka Mystique who
rescues Nightcrawler in East Berlin is a shout-out
to their history in the comic books where
Mystique is actually Nightcrawler's mother
and his father is Azazel.
When the cage fight announcer introduces Angel
as the "Angel of Death", it not only foreshadows
his becoming Apocalypse's horseman "Death"
in this film, but it's also a reference to
the same thing happening in the comics.
In the movie, like in the comics, Apocalypse
also transforms Angel into Archangel pushing
him through a painful process of shedding
his old feather wings and growing new metal
ones that can shoot metal feathers like knives.
By the way, the track playing during this
scene is, appropriately enough, heavy metal
band Metallica's 'The Four Horsemen'.
The underground business that the mutant Caliban
runs in the movie is a nod to the time he
spent in the comics with the underground mutant
community the Morlocks.
In the comics, Caliban has the power to sense
and track where other mutants are within a
certain distance and in the film his job is
to track down mutants for the right price.
The comic book Caliban becomes Apocalypse's
horseman "Pestilence", but in the movie, it's
his henchwoman Psylocke who takes on this
role.
Psylocke has a rather limited role in X-Men:
Apocalypse, but she does get a number of nods
to her comic book characteristics.
She gets a comic book faithful, albeit impractical,
costume and a pair of pink telekinetic katanas
which she can slice through just about anything
with including, as we see in this movie, a
car.
Magneto's story of trying to live with his
family among ordinary people in Eastern Europe
is based on a similar storyline from the X-Men
comics, where he lives with a Romani woman
called Magda.
In the comics, they have a daughter called
Anya, rather than Nina, as she's called in
the movie.
Similar to the film, tragedy befalls Magneto
when his daughter dies in a fire.
When police prevent Magneto from going in
to save Anya, he lashes out and kills them
all, as he does in the movie.
Comic book Magneto also loses his wife Magda
when she flees afraid of what he's become.
By the way, in the comics Magda later gives
birth to Magneto's children Wanda and Pietro,
aka Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver.
In the movie, during his time in Poland, Magneto
takes on the alias Henryk, which is a nod
to when he changed his name in the comics
to Eric Lensherr, which is, of course, the
name he goes by in the X-Men movie universe.
Magneto's daughter Nina's ability to communicate
telepathically with animals such as the deer
we see by the house or the birds she uses
to attack the police is a reference to the
comic-book mutant Lin Li, aka Nature Girl,
who has antlers on her head and who can bond
with and control animals.
At the end of the movie, Cyclops gets a new
visor and an iconic costume complete with
shoulder straps similar to the Jim Lee design
in the 1990s comics.
The argument the school jock has with Scott
about having his eyes on his girl is a little
inside joke to the rivalry between James Marsden's
Cyclops and Wolverine over Scott's girlfriend
Jean Grey in the original X-Men movie trilogy.
And the jacket Scott Summer's bully wears
has the words Wedgewood Pirates on the back,
possibly a wink to the space pirate Corsair
who's Scott's father in the comics, especially
as Scott says his bully looks old enough to
be the father of their female classmate.
Storm's mohawk matches the hairstyle makeover
she got in the 1983 comic Uncanny X-Men No.
173.
And her pickpocketing skills also have their
origins in the comics, where an orphaned Storm
learned the art of stealing on the streets
of Cairo, and even tried to pick Professor
X's pocket.
Mystique also gets a new sleeveless white
costume by the end of the movie, in reference
to her classic white outfits from the comics.
At the end of the movie, Mystique is clearly
training the new team in Professor X's Danger
Room.
There's a tease of the classic X-Men robot
foes the Sentinels as they march into the
Danger Room for training.
We last saw the Sentinels in Days of Future
Past, but the X-Men also previously trained
against a simulated Sentinel at the beginning
of X-Men: The Last Stand.
Although it feels like Jubilee's role was
cut down in the final edit, her character
does get a nice easter egg to her comic book
origin when she visits the shopping mall with
Scott, Jean and Nightcrawler.
In the comics, Jubilee runs away from an orphanage
and hides out in a shopping mall, discovering
her mutant powers while trying to get away
from a security guard.
When everyone wakes up at the X-Mansion during
Jean's nightmare, Professor X tells several
young mutants to return to their rooms, referencing
Mary Poppins when he says "spit-spot, back
to bed!"
When Charles goes to Moira's office and learns
she has a son, his reaction not only reflects
the shock and disappointment he feels as he
fancies Moira, but it's also a nod to her
son in the comics.
In the comics, Moira's son Kevin becomes the
deadly villain Proteus and Bryan Singer has
mentioned that he'd like Proteus to appear
in a future X-Men movie.
The scene also alludes to Charles and Moira's
romantic relationship in the comics and their
kiss at the end of First Class.
When Charles battles Apocalypse, the stress
of using his powers causes him to lose his
hair, which in the comics happens in his teens
again as a result of his mutant powers.
And the way Apocalypse grows in size as he
and Charles fight each other is a nod to his
giant size in the comics and how he's able
to change his size there.
The opening scene where Apocalypse is trapped
in a collapsing pyramid is an homage to the
1955 movie Land of the Pharaohs, in which
the villain Princess Nellifer played by Joan
Collins is deliberately trapped inside the
Pharaoh's tomb by a huge stone.
Magneto's words to Charles "Doesn't it ever
wake you up in the middle of the night, the
feeling that someday, they'll come for you
and your children?" and Charles' reply "I
feel a great swell of pity for the poor soul
that comes to my school looking for trouble"
are almost a direct echo of what Magneto and
Charles said to each other at the very end
of the first X-Men movie.
And there's a callback to X-Men 2 when Professor
X reads from TH White's novel, The Once And
Future King, at the X-Mansion.
At the end of the second X-Men film, Charles
asked his students if they'd ever read the
book and earlier in the film Magneto was reading
it while he was imprisoned in his plastic
cell.
The book also makes a number of appearances
in the X-Men comics, for example, in X-Tinction
Agenda, it's said to be Professor X's favourite
book.
Charles actually quotes from The Once And
Future King that "the past must be obliterated
and a new start made.
Let us now start fresh without remembrance
rather than live forward and backward at the
same time", which is an inside joke that pokes
fun at the confusing and often-times inconsistent
timeline of the X-Men movie franchise.
There's also a funny moment when Charles says
about Moira that she looks like she's barely
aged a day, which again is the filmmakers
poking fun at the franchise's inconsistencies
as actress Rose Byrne who plays Moira certainly
doesn't look 20 years older than she does
in First Class, the events of which took place
2 decades before the events of this movie.
And there's another joke about the X-Men franchise
when Jubilee, Jean Grey, Cyclops and Nightcrawler
exit the movie theatre having just seen Return
of the Jedi.
When Jean says "we can all agree that the
third one is the worst", it's a joke by writer
Simon Kinberg that The Last Stand which he
also wrote is generally considered to be the
worst movie in the first X-Men trilogy.
Bryan Singer is a huge Star Trek fan and building
on the Star Trek reference in Days of Future
Past, the 1967 Star Trek episode "Who Mourns
For Adonais?"
plays in the background on the TV at Storm's
house in Cairo after she brings Apocalypse
back to her home.
The god Apollo who appears in the episode
shares a similarity with Apocalypse, calling
the members of the Enterprise his "children"
and later also growing to a gigantic size
just like Apocalypse does.
Actress Ally Sheedy plays Scott Summers' teacher,
who we see educating her students about the
history of the 1973 Paris Peace Accords, in
other words, the events of Days of Future
Past.
It's fun to see Sheedy playing a teacher,
especially as she orders Scott to see the
School Principal for disrupting the class,
as one of Sheedy's most famous roles is in
director John Hughes' coming-of-age movie
The Breakfast Club where she played compulsive
liar Allison, who spends a whole Saturday
in detention with four other high-school students.
Stan Lee gets a new X-Men cameo, this time
joined by his wife Joan Lee, as they watch
the world's nuclear missiles being fired into
space by Apocalypse.
The post-credits scene includes a nice tease
for the supervillain Mr Sinister.
In the scene we see a trio of suited men walking
into the Alkali Lake Weapon X facility where
they pick up a vial labelled Weapon X DNA.
The vial is then stored in a briefcase labelled
Essex Corp, with Essex referring to Dr Nathanial
Essex from the comics.
Essex is a Darwinist geneticist obsessed with
developing a superior species and he's transformed
into Mr Sinister by none other than Apocalypse.
In the comics, Mr Sinister has a history of
cloning other mutants and the vial of Weapon
X DNA is a big easter egg to Wolverine's female
clone X-23 appearing in either Wolverine 3
or future X-Men movies.
And if you'd like a more detailed breakdown
of that scene and its implications for the
X-Men movie universe, you can click right
here for my full video on the post-credits.
So those were all the easter eggs and references
I spotted in X-Men Apocalypse, but I'm sure
you noticed others too and I'd love to hear
about them in the comments section.
Also make sure you're subscribed for a chance
to win this pack of cool X-Men merch.
And you can click on the Gleam link in the
video description below for bonus ways to
enter the giveaway.
If you enjoyed this video, you might like
to watch my full post-credits breakdown of
what the Mr Sinister tease means for Wolverine
3 and other X-Men movies, or for more easter
eggs you could check out my video of all the
easter eggs and references from Captain America
Civil War.
Click any of the links here to check those
out.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!